his images were put up across Beirut's
southern suburbs Qasem Soleimani is
being mourned in Hezbollah stronghold
for the iranian-backed group and it's
mainly Shia supporters the late head of
the elite couldas force the
Revolutionary Guards external wing was
their commander the public face symbol
an architect of the Islamic Republic's
influence across the region was killed
in a US drone strike in Baghdad on
Friday
since then Iran and its regional allies
have been promising revenge I'll be
clear the response is to target the
American military presence in the region
their American military bases their
vessels every American officer and
soldier in our region in our countries
on our soul nasrallah said Suleiman II
was not only Iran's concern but the
entire so-called axis of resistance a
term used to refer to groups in Iraq
Syria Lebanon Yemen and the Palestinian
territories he said it was up to those
groups to decide if and how they would
retaliate but the Hezbollah leader
hinted Lebanon will not necessarily be
an arena Lebanon is not a frontline of
America and everyone's rivalry there is
a US Embassy in a few soldiers who
trained our army but Hezbollah has a
presence in the region it can take part
in any retaliation outside the country
it now seems clear what the retaliation
may involve Iranian military commanders
made the same threat and Iran's allies
in Iraq have already singled out US
bases as targets ending the US presence
in the region is in Nasrallah's words
fair punishment if Iran is attacked by
the United States Iran will not stand
alone is what he's promised it is an
expected statement of support from an
ally which has grown into a regional
force photos are emerging of nasrallah
with Saleh many who the Hezbollah leader
called a brother he confirmed the late
military commander was in Lebanon before
heading to Baghdad via Damascus while
Hezbollah doesn't hide its links with
Iran it is the strongest political
player in Lebanon it's careful to
protect that power at the time of
increasing pressures
the condition for successful retaliation
are not there because of the economic
situation because Dev Anand cannot
sustain whatsoever to war likeable - in
2006 Nasrallah called Suleiman is
assassination a turning point and a new
phase the message here maybe one of
defiance but in reality the u.s. maximum
pressure campaign on Iran and its allies
seems to be already in a new phase Zahra
Hodor al Jazeera Beirut